for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so there's nothing really totally new in
this video just sort of a filler to kind
of get you think about the big picture
as we move on to quantum theory so
classically matter was viewed as being
particle like and massive and energy was
viewed as being wave-like and continuous
so of course all these different
experiments occurred right we had blank
who found out that energy is quantized
Einstein had the photoelectric effect
bore his model showed us an explanation
for Adams energy being quantized to
really discuss how matter to travel in
waves with his equation Davidson germer
showed electron diffraction patterns and
Compton showed that photons momentum
changing giving it a part of a like
nature so all that sort of stuff led to
to the situation that is accounted for
in quantum theory and that matter and
energy are both particle like and wave
like and so matter and energy both have
wave particle duality okay this is an
important concept to keep in mind when
thinking about wanting theory as we sort
of lead into it so I hope that video was
helpful with the sort of big picture
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying